yeah welcome to this video 24 gingham
against the International Master come
mija mija come mija mija from aruba yeah
well I don't believe that I doubt that
our buyers got any a title players maybe
some candidate made master or something
but it's ok so let's go to the the chest
is probably from somewhere else I've got
a madden modern benoni here I'm going
for this night e 2 2 g-3 Landis's very
similar to the sameish in some respect
but it delays the f3 move which has some
some benefits Bishop g5 I don't remember
now let's try that
yeah h5 is play to disturb the night
with h 5h for probably I need to go here
I interesting yeah night age 79 he wants
to prepare this and after that pledge
form but i can i can cancel and drop to
h1 now this is not the problem wyd
doesn't mind to play f3 and night f2 and
this is what i'm doing now the night s
has a good square on f2 controlling a
portent squares it term it protects the
for porn which will both come under
attack out with f5 very soon if black
doesn't go for for some f5 um activity
and he's very often just too passive
what this is surprising does he want
what i don't understand the move at all
can even just play Bishop g5 what about
this am I not winning this pawn it's
also strategically very very curious the
smooth because he must play a five
everything he doesn't have any other
play you can consider night to h5 maybe
he wants to put night h5 now and trying
for some some kind of fishy counterplay
possible with the night on f2 but the
night on f form sorry not f2 of course i
don't really don't really understand if
i go Queen d2 and maybe he can go to
deform these kind of positions are
notoriously tricky even if they're crap
mostly but they're tricky ok let's grab
it it's not not necessary but yeah I
need to of course get get rid of this
bishop the question is how i know i
don't like night f4 want to protect the
square
and I probably need to play King edge 1
let some some point let's do this now
this means i have ideas like Knight to
g4 or losing this night now naija for is
not a ridiculous idea at intense Knight
f6 night h6 and it would open up the F
file it destroys them a structure but
this is from a dynamic point of view
interesting wait what am I talking about
what what about just f4 f4 where does he
go this this piece doesn't have a square
and now it has a square but for this
bishop okay it basically didn't have a
square I can take now play at five and
this is yeah come on to keep it simple
and this is basically over 25 is
steadily trapping all the pieces to be
sure bungee form
yeah no move Quincy flag wins yeah
Knight to f6 allowing Bishop g5 simply
simply concede the game I think you
cannot give up the h-bond maybe he made
some this was some kind of smart move
mistake clicking the night and then it
just moved or something I don't know it
doesn't have any any useful idea this
move this year I mean that age to have
sex if six is just just completely
useless may be clicked on the square or
something that sometimes happens those
kind of mouse slip type of mistakes okay
so um but that still need to win it age
three and it probably will play Queen h7
and try some some silly tactics h h
three will win it anyway so i can also
just go here think
yeah but at the end I always have h3 and
win the bishop here check check
a stream and that's the bishop
so what is this two extra points yeah no
it's not it's winning but I was hoping
for more still need to to play this okay
so how do how do you win this now yeah
go 45 m probably
d 6 maybe d 6 and Ruby 7 oh come on
let's not spend too much time
you cannot go to d2 because of rogue f
6m this is the IDM okay and now I've got
the a porn I also wanted to exchange
some material to make it easier the a
porn and the japon combined really
should should win this maybe this first
you threatening 97
97 yeah come on yeah right end game oh
the night is trapped wow I completely
forgot about that okay but I've got the
Jeep on it's probably still winning but
I completely overlooked that the night
is strapped very stupid check check time
morning checkmate yeah okay it was
probably all right from a technical
point of view and still I thought here
it is just resins maybe I have something
better I can go h3 but I thought what
irritates me here was the Queen hl7
resource if I go here I thought Queen
h7s maybe maybe retaining this this year
Jack and I'm not sure what's going on
but computer points out with
justification of course I can take here
and this is winning completely I mean
just winning a piece not just two extra
pawns what I did is probably winning as
well but it's not it's not as decisive f
6m is the computer suggestion are very
strong f7 wow yeah this is even stronger
f6 is just resigned some ok and this day
this is bad i mean here that i let it
come to this black can fight here i can
take on a three Wow check
and then I've spoiled all my advantage
very silly yeah f6 star is the clear the
cleanest why he f6 threatened screen g5
and he has no way to rescue the pieces
simply no way threatening this end he
needs to play a move like Jack something
like this and this is just just too much
a couple of points plus the attack yeah
it all began with this Knight f6 ouch
here 90 f6 is just probably some some
sort of mouse slip because this is so
obviously picks up the phone and wins
the game basically he needs to play for
f5 maybe instantly may be here and then
continuing this this way i don't know
maybe night here or something like this
and this is a pretty normal positioned
for for those kind of for those kind of
lines yeah thanks for watching
interesting game